uh obviously that was the last thing
that anyone thought
was actually happening and rich had the
wherewithal to
did he call you you were in your hotel
room didn't he call you up
you want to take that rich it was uh so
it was in toronto
and we were all gonna go have a steak
after wrapping it up on sunday
and so the group jared jensen misha uh
cliff
myself and we were gonna go and rob
it was on that that list of people were
gonna walk across the street like it's
like down the block
and go have a steak which we've done the
year before kind of a
thing we did in toronto and rob was
still signing autographs we left so i
will just meet you there robbie and you
kind of like all right
places on we're waiting we're waiting
we're waiting
and i text him
you know hey we're waiting and he's like
not feeling it
and that is like did not sound like rob
like not feeling it like we've been
busting our hump for 72 hours you're not
gonna come
what so i called him and i said hey
we're we're
all waiting we're not gonna order until
you get here because we don't you know
we're
get out of here i ordered a martini and
he was like riches
i i don't know i'm like what do you mean
you don't know
i got a feeling you know i'm like dude
you're stressed
yeah i know you you're around like a
banjo string you probably all you know
you know riddled with anxiety get up get
out of the eye of the storm
come on go over here and he's like no
i don't know i'm not gonna do it and we
hung up and i was like
none of that made sense to me and i
can't explain why i just went back to
the guys and i said
this doesn't make sense man i'm going
back i'm going to the hotel this is not
something doesn't make sense it just
didn't sound right it just
like and i always make the joke i've
never known rob to turn down a free
martini
but that's the simple way of saying it
but it was like there's just something
not right the way he was phrasing it
the energy that i know we just had in
the middle of the day and we were
planning on this and just to do a 180
like that
i'm like it's like like when a 911
person knows oh there's somebody with a
gun to this person's head on the other
line at the
other end of the phone i should send the
cops like it was just a weird moment
was he mumbling at all was he was he was
it a mumble kind of like slurred
speechless
indecisive he wasn't slurring he he
and i know this sounds again like a bit
but rob's
sort of natural speech pattern and
remember it was going to progress and
get worse as the night went on but at
this moment
his natural speech patter pattern
lent itself to not revealing what was
going on
his sort of you know comedic like ah you
know i mean
really you know that became the speech
pattern
but he wasn't coming out of it it was
like he would just just keep doing that
as opposed to rich i'm not feeling good
man i gotta lay down i'm
shot that's a sentence i could go oh
okay
but it was more like ash
you know it's just i just feel i don't
know man
and you're like okay you know it just
didn't seem right
it just didn't seem right so you went to
the hotel you did you go up to the room
i went to the hotel went to the room and
there was one of the handlers there
who had walked him back to his room and
she
looked concerned i'm like what we have
handlers walking us to and from our
rooms
and she's like i don't know man he just
seemed out of at the end of the
autograph
session i'm like okay i'll go talk to
him
and she goes but he doesn't want anybody
in there and they're like well i'm going
in there
and and i went in there and it's talking
to him and he's like i
don't know man i just blah blah
you know kind of him and han i'm like
okay and i said dude are you okay he's
like i just you know
and i thought he was having an anxiety
attack you know i thought something had
gotten
gotten him worked up and i'm like i
this is okay this is odd there's a
there's a guy who's a sound guy
who had a has a you know i don't use a
practicing physician anymore but he had
been
and i said you know i told the gals like
maybe go grab him
and bring him up here meanwhile i'm
talking to him and he's like i just want
to watch the
you know the game i'm like okay
cool football game and i call misha it's
mitch's phone and i'm like
something right this that something's
this is not right uh
i'm gonna have to hang here you know and
he's like misha is like put him on the
phone so put him on the phone with misha
misha talked to him for a second
and he got on the phone he's like yeah
something's not right because the way
rob was hammering on and i was like
rob who's the quarterback of the team
you're playing who you you know who's
that guy
you know and i'm like dude doesn't know
like he's not saying
anything he's like could it be a stroke
and i'm like
i don't know but it ain't right and the
doc came up
sat with him had him talked to him for a
little bit how to do a few tests and he
said
it's not a stroke he's having an anxiety
attack
let's let him sleep it off i said okay
and he left the room
and i'm like that dude's wrong i'm not
do i'm not
i'm not leaving the hospital what i
wanted to do was sleep i just remember
the time i just wanted to sleep and i
was like dude i gotta take you to the
doctor and you're like no no i don't go
to the doctor i'm like
i know i'm the if i'm wrong
dinner's on me but i gotta take it if he
would have slept and you would have said
fine because a lot of people it's a long
day you're out with your friends you're
thinking of things you want to go out
for drink watch football
you go eyes tired most of the time it's
just fatigue it's anxiety
i get that if you let rob go to sleep we
might not have rob is that
fair to say yes yeah
at the very least i may not you know
never have uh
been able to speak i mean it was it was
i was losing words and i couldn't
what he i think what he really saw
was that i was having a hard time
putting anything together putting words
together right it wasn't comic stick
anymore like i was like
didn't i put didn't i did i when i was
watching the game didn't i
like call the football a banana or
something like that that's something i
remember i can't i wish i could remember
exactly what it was it was also
something in that framework now this at
this point i've already said we're going
to the doctor i already leaned out and i
said
girls get a car not an ambulance get a
car we're driving to the hospital we're
not gonna make a scene
we're just gonna get out of here and so
they were wrestling up a car and you're
sitting there and you
you used a word incorrectly dramatically
so like
oh he just uh scored a bookshelf and
you're like yeah man
okay like you know he you did something
with the word replacement that you're
like right
and then we go to the hospital and this
is the thing that was
so i'm still thinking and rob you'd leap
in any time man
i know it's your story but i just like
i'm still thinking
i'm wrong it's anxiety i'm being overly
cautious here but you know what i'm
gonna err on caution but in my mind i'm
like
you know how this plays out you get over
there and you find out your buddy's got
indigestion not a heart
problem like you know whatever and we
get over there
and there's a pretty full waiting room
like there would be in any emergency
room
and we go up to sign in
and i go hey my buddy here is having a
hard time like putting thoughts together
and
i don't know maybe nothing but a little
concerned and she goes okay what's his
name
and i go or what's your name and i go
it's rob benedict she's like no no i
need him to talk to me
uh what's your name and you go and
immediately she's pushing a button under
the table
like immediately i see her pushing
something and
five seconds later while he's going rob
benedict
four doctors walk out turns out
by accident we're at toronto's premier
stroke center hospital
it happened to be the closest hospital
we went to